we begin tonight with the migration
crisis at the u.s mexico border the
united states has begun flying would-be
asylum seekers out of a texas border
town a makeshift camp at the del rio
international bridge has quickly grown
to more than 12 thousand migrants most
of them from haiti local residents say
they don't have the resources to help
them
[Music]
thousands of haitians have crossed the
border from mexico to the united states
ending up in makeshift camps in texas
living under this bridge they lack the
basic necessities no shelter food water
or sanitation more than 12 000 people
are waiting to be processed by
immigration authorities
many made the desperate journey through
central and south america fleeing
poverty violence and natural disasters
looking for a better life for the past
week migrants have been crossing the rio
grande from mexico into the town of del
rio in the us trying to bring food and
other supplies for their families
there's not enough food for everyone in
the camp it's very bad we have to leave
to look for food
overwhelmed by the influx of migrants
the u.s government is trying to stem the
flow border agents have stepped up
security preventing people from entering
and leaving many in limbo
with the mexican guards here i can't
cross here and i also can't cross there
there are no options because i could
keep going to the us but if i go back to
mexico they'll send me back and i'll
lose the money i have
some are being moved to shelters and
immigration processing centers but
they've been scarred by the harrowing
journeys that brought them here
coming up
i walked and ran with migration
officials chasing us
not all people are good
there are bad ones too and they scammed
us in other countries too
they took our money
we survived a lot of calamities
while a humanitarian crisis unfolds the
u.s and mexican authorities have ordered
the deportation of hundreds of haitians
thousands more could follow it could
become one of america's biggest
expulsions of migrants or refugees in
decades
and for more now we want to go to our
washington bureau chief enos post she is
at the border crossing in del rio right
now enos it's good to have you with us
you've been talking to people there what
have they been telling you and what's
happening at the border right now
vibrant behind me behind this fence
people are being put in buses at this
very moment and some of them will be
brought to airports and be flown out to
haiti as soon as possible we talked to
the border control and asked them if you
could enter and do our jobs as
journalists and report on what exactly
is happening here behind this fence but
they didn't allow us in
and so can we describe
what the conditions are like
underneath this bridge where all of
these would-be asylum seekers are are
living
it's extremely hot here it's more than a
40 degree celsius in the shade that
means over 100 degrees fahrenheit and
again this is in the shade therefore all
these refugees kind of hide see search
for some shelter under this bridge the
the circumstances are devastating we
could talk to some people who have been
there uh last night they don't have any
food we heard that in your report there
are hardly any
toilets there's hardly any water
one woman went into labor so the
situation is just devastating and the
the us has launched this mass expulsion
of haitian migrants from texas and what
message
is the u.s trying to send to people who
are trying to reach the u.s
well brent there is one picture out on
twitter from a colleague i think this
will be the iconic picture of this uh
event if one can say so of that what is
happening here right now is a picture of
border control on horses they are
cracking their whips on haitian refugees
trying to prevent them from
coming here to the united states seeking
asylum seeking some human treatment and
this is the exact uh kind of message the
administration the biden administration
wants to send if you come here we will
send you back even if that means we sent
you back to a place like haiti
and it is you are describing
what is obviously a crisis at the border
and yet the biden administration still
refuses to call it
a crisis
well brenda these are the worst images
for joe biden at this moment he's facing
harsh critiques anyhow because of his
withdrawal
from afghanistan which led to tens of
thousands of afghan refugees already
seeking asylum here in the united states
he gets
harshly criticized by his opponents
of his refugee policy anyhow so
i'm sure that he also doesn't want to
come here because he doesn't want to be
associated with these pictures so he
just tries to kind of resolve this
crisis as soon as possible by sending
these people back
all right our very own enos poll in del
rio in texas tonight enos thank you